committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20204 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronics
this is a public hearing on senate bills
actually on an amendment to a senate
bill
referred to this committee with the
potential for executive sessions
to be held throughout we will
be holding an executive session on
senate bill 96
immediately following your information
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary to participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general torque website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and with rsa 91a
right to know law anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call
271 3600
or email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled we do have one staff
member who
is listening in with us today
and that is our committee researcher gen
four
please note that all votes that will be
taken during this meeting will be done
by roll call
vote and we're going to begin our
meeting by taking roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required
pursuant to the right to know mr clerk
would you call the role
you mr chairman representative alexander
um i'm here in the people
representative uh i'm here in west milan
alone
representative chase
um representative chase is not here she
there are substitutes and i believe
representative gordon i mean chair
gordon knows
um we we're missing two uh people
representative chase and representative
macbeth and representative catherine
rogers and representative lucius
parshall are the substitutes
i should have mentioned that at the
beginning of the meeting that we do have
four substitutes here today
and we should welcome representative
melvin who's filling in for
representative rice
representative rogers who's filling in
for representative chase
representative renzolo who is filling in
for representative
representative parshall who is filling
in for representative david
and if i could just make a correction
there it's partial thank you so much
thank you mr partial marshall
p-a-r-s-h-a-l-m
okay where are we at representative
rogers i'm here in concord
uh i'm alone in my apartment
representative here in my home office in
new market and i'm alone
i'm here in the committee room with my
colleagues
i'm here in the committee room
by myself representative kelly
i'm here in temple by myself at the
moment and i'd like to point out that it
doesn't look like representative rogers
is alone
good morning i am here in durham
currently alone roommates maybe
throughout the room throughout the
day thank you representative
good morning i'm here in manchester and
my husband is around
representative marshall
i know you're here yes i am here thank
you so much
i'm alone in my realm representative
mclean
i'm here in the community room at the
llv representative
good morning i'm in exeter alone in my
home
representative here in the lobby
president murder here in federal
representative simpson
hello i'm here in exeter alone at the
moment my spouse and sons may be through
the room at some point
representative smith uh good morning
um i'm alone in durham representatives
representative here in the committee
room
mayor buffer is here in the community
representative you're not you're not you
know
i've been booted from the committee all
right
sylvia here thank you in the room
thank you we have a full committee in
attendance
we're here this morning to hear
a non-germanic amendment this is
amendment 2021-1244-h
an amendment offered by representative
burch i would note that
prior to the hearing i received notice
that uh that
26 people registered in support of this
amendment 1178
registered in opposition and
six registered as who there are eight
people who have registered
uh pre-registered to testify of those
people
three have registered to testify in
support
it's 11 people registered in opposition
and four people registered as neutral
i know that most people
registered to speak for approximately
three minutes
there are a couple of people who
registered for five but
i expect that we should be able to get
through our hearing relatively quickly
this morning
the uh and what we'll do is we'll call
upon those people first who
pre-registered
if other people are have con online and
wish to testify
we'll have them raise their hands at the
end of the pre-registered people that
they'll have the opportunity to testify
if they wish to do so
and with that i'm going to call upon
representative burch first if he would
like to
introduce or speak to his amendment
thank you mr chair uh just as a matter
of procedure
do we already have a motion on the floor
as to
sb 96 overall so that i can introduce an
amendment
um i don't remember from last
time we met well it's uh hearing on the
motion
if if you would like to if you would
like to make a motion
to accept that i think that would be
fine and then we can act on that
all right just just for procedural
reasons
i would move otp on sb96
it happens yes okay
i'm told i'm told uh that
i'm all messed up and that the amendment
should be offered in the executive
session
so if that's the case you can just
testify
to the uh to your amendment all right
um but i don't need to formally
introduce it at this point
i see a no from the clerk so i will
proceed
um and colleagues it's it's good to be
speaking with you again in favor of this
proposed legislation
i'll try not to be too repetitive of
earlier testimony
and you'll have the opportunity to hear
from some recognized experts
on this issue this legislation
guarantees the citizens of our state
have a right to go to state court for
redress of harms
done to them by the government this
legislation is not as complicated as
some would make it
an activist supreme court tried an
experiment in 1982
to provide qualified immunity to protect
some government actors
this experiment has been widely
considered a failure
and now the us congress and many states
are seeking to end this failure
this proposed legislation does three
things
by eliminating qualified immunity it
returns the law to how it was in 1982
pre-1982 it provides a path to state
court in addition to a currently
existing route to federal court
and it shifts the burden of any
financial penalty and costs from the
individual bad actor
to his or her government employer
in addition to some technical changes of
language
the amendment makes some changes and
clarifies some important aspects from hb
by putting some things into statute
is made explicit in this amendment
that state county and municipal
employees who are acting
in a judicial or legislative capacity
select board members aldermen commission
members and the like
will keep their immunity from suit in
their personal capacity
as they always have had it is made
explicit in this legislation
that the acts of state employees are to
be examined
in the light of what a reasonable state
employee
should have done given all the
circumstances existing at the time
the action was taken the employee must
act reasonably
the determination of reasonableness must
embody
allowance for the fact that employees
are sometimes forced to make judgments
in circumstances that are unclear about
what is necessary in a particular
situation
and finally the amendment removes the
alleged bad actor from lawsuits
clarifies and makes certain that the
individual actors not to be held
financially liable
why is this legislation necessary
when police oops when police wrecked a
woman's home
by bombarding it with tear gas grenade
grenades after she agreed to let them in
to arrest her former boyfriend
no civil liability due to qualified
immunity
when a sheriff who shot a 10 year old
boy while trying to kill his dog
no qualified immunity when a sheriff
responding to an erroneous
domestic assault report grabbed the
purported victim in a bear hug
threw her to the ground and broke her
broke her collarbone
no civil liability due to qualified
immunity
when police officers stole cash and
property worth two hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars while executing a
search warrant
no civil liability due to qualified
immunity
then there's the question of sununu
youth center
where hundreds of claims have been made
of sexual
and other abuse of children by state
employees
if that in fact did happen
should those abusers and their employer
be protected from civil suit by their
victims because of qualified immunity
let's clear up a few misconceptions this
legislation has nothing to do with
frivolous lawsuits
the courts have and will continue to
have plenty of power
to dismiss frivolous suits and impose
sanctions financial and otherwise
on those who file them studies in
colorado and california debunked the
claim
that municipal costs will increase to
any significant degree with this type of
legislation
if there are costs that is due solely to
the misconduct
by state actors not legislation
it helps the time to return to basic
principles
the first is something every person here
probably subscribes to
the citizen is in a higher position than
the government
the government works for the citizen not
the other way around
this is a bedrock conservative principal
a bedrock libertarian principal
and a bedrock liberal principal
basic principle number two when the
government
harms a citizen the government then
cannot decide the citizen has no redress
that the citizen is out of luck the
government gives itself immunity
from the citizen our founders in new
hampshire had it exactly
right 1784 when they wrote part 1
article 14 of our constitution
legal remedies to be free complete and
prompt every subject
of this state is entitled to a certain
remedy
by having recourse to the laws for all
injuries
he may receive in his personal property
or character
and goes on from there
i have no quarrel with those who are
focused on the potential liability
of county and local and state entities
who continue
who employ or continue to employ people
who violate constitutional rights of
citizens
our county executive committee does our
budget in cheshire county
i've served on it for nine years i'm
currently chair
i know much of what there is to know
about county budgets
and i know two things this legislation
will not
cost local governments money bad
behaving employees
will cost local entities money
you want to avoid these costs higher
well train well
we self-insure in cheshire county and we
put our focus on
hiring and training well
i also have no quarrel with either the
lobbyists for the municipalities
a thoughtful and by the way very nice
person
uh nor with lobbyists for police unions
i support unions and what they do for
their members
but their job is to look after the
narrow interests
of their particular clients and to
direct your attention
specifically to the interests of their
employers
a slice of the pie as it were their job
is not to look after
the public interest that's our job
as many of you know i was a career
public defender
my job basically was to get my clients
off with the leastest
consistent with the rules and ethical
guidelines
it's not my job to look out for the
public interest that was the job of
others
similarly the job of lobbyists for the
police and municipalities is not to look
out for the public interest
just to get their clients off so to
speak with the leases
that's honorable that's not the job of
this committee
or the legislature we need to look at
the whole pie
not just a slice and i think it's
inescapable
that the qualified immunity is a failed
experiment
not in the public interest i do have a
bit of a quarrel
with what i received yesterday from the
lobbyist
for the new hampshire municipal
association
um the uh and i assume the committee
received the same
uh letter uh in it the claim was made
that if this amendment were passed
litigation and insurance costs will rise
municipalities will have even more
trouble recruiting employees individuals
will be reluctant
the servant town government there will
be absolutely no positive effects
on the behavior of municipal employees
or officials
frankly this is virtually word for word
what we heard
from the same folks several years ago
when we considered removing standing
or uh changing the laws of standing
to allow taxpayers to sue in our state
something that was approved by this
committee approved by the house and
senate and approved by the public
and guess what we were told that
litigation insurance costs would rise
nope didn't happen municipalities will
have trouble recruiting employees nope
didn't happen individuals will be
reluctant to serve in town government
nope didn't happen
there'll be no positive effects on the
behavior of this employees
now basically very few things were
brought
i want to respond specifically to the
last
claim absolutely no positive effects on
behavior municipal employees
i'm i'm saddened to read that claim
because i also read a very short time
ago
that the um the world's
largest municipal police union the
benevolent police benevolent association
for new york city
wrote to its members after new york city
recently passed qualified immunity
and they told
their members that they strongly caution
police officers to limit their searches
of individuals
or private property to cases where the
officers clearly and unequivocally
within the bounds of the law
and went on to some detail saying now
that we don't have qualified immunity
you got to really be sure that you're
operating within the strictures of the
law
well i congratulate the new york benit
police benevolent association and i
believe that's
that approach is good police work and
it's good for the community
and i reject the claim
that no positive effects will occur
uh on behavior municipal employees
or officials finally
we know that citizens are being harmed
by bad acting government employees and
these employees in the government agency
that hire them are far too
often walking away scot-free because of
a judicially invented immunity
that offends not only the new hampshire
constitution
but defends on who we are as granite
staters
the doors to our courts must be kept
open to redress wrongs done to our
citizens
that's what this legislation will
accomplish thank you
thank you are there any questions for
representative burch
yes representative here good morning now
um they take my question you named off
some scenarios
this morning one was where a young boy
was shot by the police
over the dog a tear gas incident in the
home
and also about 250 000 being stolen
during a search warrant
were these new hampshire cases or were
these cases in other states
uh as far as i know those were cases in
other states
there are uh and thank you for your
question
um there are two further comments on
that one
there are cases especially with
excessive use of force that occur
and are being litigated to some extent
because it's hard to litigate
in new hampshire and prior
events uh former uh
justice douglas has made reference to a
couple of cases that he's actively
involved in right now
which i think involved the at least one
the nashua police department
the uh the difficulty is
that you with immunity you don't know
how many of these cases exist
because let's say i am harmed
by or believe i am harmed by the action
improper action of a police officer
violated
let's say my constitutional rights i go
to
a lawyer and the lawyer says it's not
worth the time and effort to bring the
suit because it's going to get thrown
out
on qualified immunity
so i go away and there's no record of it
there's no way of
quantifying how many of those cases
exist
but they do exist some of them are being
litigated
okay representative a follow-up question
mr burch
ah representative sorry about that
new hampshire have a process to
investigate
um allegations against police officers
including use of force already
no
that they may
and there's certainly an open question
about how effective that is and how
effective it isn't
but that's a different issue than
whether
a victim in ak in a situation
has a right to go to court and ask for
redress of their harms
um a uh a process
may find that the officer acted
correctly
or incorrectly or whatever that may be
and and criminal charges may be broader
or may not be brought
this legislation has to do
with the right of you or me to go to
court
and say a government actor violated my
constitutional rights
harmed me and i want
justice thank you
representative kelly i saw your hand up
do you have a question
i did but it was answered thank you are
there any other questions for
representative verge
see none thank you for your testimony
today
you're welcome start
with our list of people who
pre-registered the first one would be
representative lim
if he's there
representative lynn if you could raise
your hand
hi can you hear me we can oh thank you
thank you very much uh
uh mr chairman and members of the
committee um
i'll i have several points i'd like to
make and i'll try to make be as brief as
possible
thank you first of all i i would say it
just initially
the although this bill has been referred
this amendment has been referred to as
an amendment that eliminates qualified
immunity the term
qualified immunity comes from
primarily from federal case law
as far as i know in the state of new
hampshire under our case law i don't
believe that there's a case
that uses the term qualified immunity
rather we refer to
statutory immunity or common law
official immunity
and i point that out simply because um
to avoid any confusion
um i think the concepts are basically
the same but
but terminology sometimes can be
important the
the first point that i would make is
that it's important for the committee to
understand that this bill
does not simply eliminate
qualified immunity or official immunity
whatever you want to call it
it also creates a constitutional cause
of action
under state law to allow to allow the
recovery of damages
and i would suggest that there is no
need for the creation of such a cause of
action
i would contrast i would ask the
committee to contrast this
with i think the argument has has been
made that this is really
creating the state law equivalent of a
federal cause of action
similar to the one authorized under uh
section 1983
of title 42 of the u.s code
the problem is there was a reason for
having
section 1983 as a to allow a
constitutional cause of action
under the fed under the federal
constitution because there is no
body of federal tort law federal tort
law as a practical matter doesn't exist
but in new hampshire we have a
well-developed body of state tort law
and in fact what any anything
as a practical matter anything that
could be characterized as a
violation of state of state
constitutional law
you know with i i can't i can't frankly
think of an exception and i would offer
i would invite somebody to
to uh offer one but anything that would
be a violation of state
constitutional law would also constitute
a common law tort in new hampshire such
as the tort of
assault for on you unlawful use of force
or excessive use of force
or battery or false imprisonment or
malicious prosecution
or trespass if for example the police
executed a search warrant without
probable clause
or invasion of privacy or interference
with contractual relations
etc there is so there is no reason to
create a
new constitutional tort when conduct
that is wrongful can be can be
a remedy under state under state common
law
um this bill also provo purports to to
allow
a claim for equitable relief but
equitable release of
qualified immunity has not been
it certainly is not a defense where
where
a litigant is seeking equitable relief
to prevent
future uh future misconduct so that's
again the qualified immunity just would
have no application there
now to the the one thing about this the
one part of this bill that i think
probably i would agree is a good idea
is to allow attorneys fees to be claimed
in in uh cases where there's a claim
uh you know of of the type that is that
would be uh
uh that would involve uh police
misconduct
um so i guess the question i would have
is why create this
new constitutional cause of action when
there's no necessity for
it and when it invites the opportunity
for just sort of creating confusion
lawyer you know good lawyers will argue
that oh well
assault and battery may prohibit this
but now this is a constitutional claim
there's some nuance that's different
let's make a let's create a new body of
law why do that
when there's really no need for that to
be done the common law provides
perfectly adequate remedies the second
point i would make is
that this amendment may be
unconstitutional to the extent that it
seeks to eliminate
the naming of individual officers as
defendants in suits based on
federal law or to the extent that it
eliminates qualified immunity
for defendants in section 1983 actions
and if you read the bill
it purports to this cause of action that
it creates is one
that would apply for violations of the
united states constitution also
although the u.s supreme court has held
that section 1983 actions can be brought
into state court
um i i firmly believe that that the
state cannot change
substantive federal law so that for
example if a suit
if the suit is based on a violation of
the federal constitution
i don't think the state would have the
authority to eliminate qualified
immunity
only the federal uh courts could do that
could do that and the same thing would
apply to eliminating uh
removing individual officers as
defendants if it was if the suit was
brought under federal law i don't think
the state could do that the third point
i think this is very important is that
this
amendment goes further than hb-111 did
in at least one important respect in
that it purports to eliminate immunity
not just for cause of act causes of
action where the law was not
clearly established at the time of the
police action
but also for cases where the officer
acted reasonably
at the time in question and i refer you
specifically
to propose rsa 507 h4
1a the second clause and rsa 507 h41b
i think this is very problematic because
reasonableness is itself
often the standard for determining
whether police action
is constitutional or unconstitutional
for example
police are allowed to make a stop if
they have reasonable suspicion that a
crime is about to be committed
or may conduct a search without us a
warrant if they reasonably
believe exigent circumstances exist does
the
does this amendment's language that
quote the court shall not be impeded by
an invocation of a state agent's
defense or immunity close quote um
uh as proposed in rsa 507 h41
where such immunity is based on the
reasonableness of the officer's conduct
mean that reasonableness is no longer to
be considered in assessing whether the
conduct was unconstitutional in the
first place
i assume that that was not what the
drafters intended but that is
but but that is a a real problem in
terms of what does what does
reasonableness mean
why is the reasonableness different here
than than reasonable
in terms of what of what the
constitutional right is in the first
place
eliminating suits against officers
personally by
providing that only the state or
municipality will be named as a
defendant
does not solve the problem of inhibiting
officers
from properly doing their jobs first
i should point out that this amendment
would eliminate personal liability
even when an officer clearly was acting
unlawful
and my question would be why would you
want to do that if an officer clearly
was violating the law why shouldn't they
be held personally liable
i would certainly think they should be
second imposing liability on the
governmental unit does not resolve the
problem
because if the municipality is to be
held liable for officers actions that
were not clearly wrong when they
occurred
such governmental units will encourage
their officers to be reticent to do
their jobs
when there is a chance that the state or
the town could be sued
the wash word for officers from their
political leaders the mayors governors
whatever
will become look away don't be curious
don't pursue suspicious activity in any
situation where your actions might be
called into question
uh later and and state or municipal
state or municipality
be held liable and the officers will
listen
particularly since this amendment
specifically says
that if the state or local government is
found liable for a constitutional
violation
even if the officer acted reasonably the
officer can be terminated from his job
notwithstanding for example any
protections that might be offered by a
collective bargaining agreement
and i for that i refer you specifically
to section
uh h61 of this proposed amendment
as can be seen from rising crime rates
around the country
all right and i don't want to cut you
short but if you could sort of wrap up
that would be great
sure all right as a rising from the past
for five minutes and we've done about
ten so i'm
i'm sorry all right uh uh as i think can
be seen from
from rising crime rates resulting from
things like defund the police movement
and other anti-police rhetoric
police hearing uh police will be
encouraged to adopt a hunker down
mentality
if this uh if this uh uh
amendment were to uh were to be adopted
so i would suggest at first that this
amendment should
should not be adopted um and that we
should that
that this matter should be studied uh
over the summer and
perhaps brought back in a more
comprehensive way in the in the fall
but so i would say just don't do
anything
kill the amendment and don't do anything
but if you if the committee feels that
some
is the need to do something i have i've
sent committee members a proposal
that i think solves the specific
problem of where qualified immunity has
been
applied improperly by some courts
without eliminating qualified immunity
and so as a fallback position i would
urge the committee to consider that
amendment
thank you very much i'm happy to answer
any questions thank you
representative smith do you have a
question
yes i do mr chairman thank you very much
um representative lynn are you
saying that the police
in the state of new hampshire
make their decisions about
how to act in certain circumstances
based on whether it would be better to
i think in your words hunkered down
than to follow
both the law and their ethical
responsibilities
as public employees i
i i'm sure i'm saying that that
certainly is a consideration i think
we've seen that kind of thing happen
around the country i mean new york city
is a perfect example
the the police have you know the message
that's gone out is
just back off you know look away
because if you don't you you know if
there's any kind of chance that you
might uh
that you're gonna end up um uh being
sued
uh that's the safer course and
unfortunately
i think that there are a number of
officers who will who will who will
decide that's the reasonable choice to
be made and we shouldn't be encouraging
that
could i could i just follow up quickly i
know that representative lynn has taken
a lot of time
and i don't want to exacerbate the
situation
um but are you also saying um
representative lynn that those people
and there's in
uh with the responsibility of hiring
public officials therefore
should not exercise the most
rigorous investigation in terms of
hiring and in terms of training
and in terms of supervising and in terms
of holding people accountable
because it would be better just to let
anybody in
and then let them do what they want to
do i'm not
i'm not saying that at all i don't i'm
not suggesting that in the slightest i
think it's absolutely important that
that
police officers be you know trained very
very well and that they be held
accountable
i have no question about that whatsoever
thank you any other questions for
representative glenn
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
ross conway
thank you mr chairman can you hear me
yeah
excellent well thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for holding
this hearing today
just for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity in new
hampshire
uh and just to clear it up uh we are in
support of the amendment we're neutral
on sb 96 in totality
um this amendment is quite
straightforward
it makes changes to hb 111 as we've
heard
uh and these changes address much of the
feedback and concern we heard from the
debate on hb 111.
specifically it ensures the employee's
name will not be listed on the suit
instead listing the government entity or
employer
this amendment also makes clear that
legislative immunity will still apply to
all elected officials
this includes local elected local
elected officials
who the courts have determined fall
under the doctrine of legislative
immunity
not qualified immunity and this uh these
changes
also uh do not apply to the
judicial branch this amendment will
not have the an effect on good
government employees but instead
creates a remedy for the few bad actors
in government
who violate citizen rights currently if
a citizen's rights have been violated by
a government agent
there are very few avenues for the
citizen to hold the government
accountable for the actions of the
employee
this type of undermining of
accountability leads to an erosion of
trust between
citizens and its government particularly
in law enforcement
qualified immunity allows few officers
who do not
allows the few officers who do not who
do
violate sorry a person's rights from
being held accountable
which makes a good officer's job much
harder
we live in a constitutional republic if
our constitutional rights are being
violated by the government
then that one bad actor in government
breeds distrust across the entire
population
as we have seen and it's important to
remember that qualified immunity
only becomes relevant after it is
determined that the government has
violated a person's constitutional
rights
public officials specifically law
enforcement is already given great
deference on what is reasonable
and what isn't objectively reasonable
decisions are protected by the
constitution
with or without qualified immunity
qualified immunity is also completely
antithetical to the spirit and founding
principles of new hampshire
it harkens back to the days of the
divine right of kings
which was the idea that since the kings
are appointed by god
they could only be held accountable by
god new hampshire's was one of the first
places on earth to challenge that idea
ebenezer mudjit josiah bartlett and john
stark stood up to the
to the stood up to the monarchy in
defense of citizens rights
for a more accountable government for
and by the people
our entire structure of government was
built upon accountability
that is why we have an executive council
to provide a check on executive power of
the governor
it is why we have one of the largest
legislatures in the world
government and its employees should not
be above the law
and they should be and they should not
be above accountability
from the people they serve we must
restore this trust in
in our government and reforming the good
doctrine of qualified immunity will go a
long way towards doing just that
this amendment is simply about
government accountability
transparency and upholding our
fundamental constitutional rights
and for these reasons we urge the
committee to approve this amendment to
sb96
and i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you are there any questions for mr
connolly
so thank you for your testimony today
thank you for your time
judy milner
ms milner you may have to unmute
i can't wait for the day that um my
equipment is not superior to me and i
can use an unmute
button thank you for that um i apologize
and i want to start again by saying good
morning honorable members of the house
judiciary committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today my name is judy milner and i have
the privilege of serving as the city
manager for the city of franklin
by the way it's nice to see you again
judge gordon
i am speaking today regarding the
amendment to
senate bill 96 that closely mirrors
house bill 111
which in essence revokes municipal
qualified immunity at every level
regardless of whether or not the
employee was acting in good
faith there are many unintended
consequences to this amendment
that will eliminate the protection the
protections under qualified immunity
earlier today in earlier testimony and
in testimony from house bill 111 many of
you have heard
testimony on topics such as the
amendment is overarching
not just affecting the police department
as many think the attention of this
legislation is
but affects all facets of municipal
government
from administration to code enforcement
to building permits
to public works recreation school
districts
and to our volunteer not elected
boards and commissions this amendment
punishes the municipality for good
and bad acting employees and it may have
further unattended consequences
of having employees hesitate to act when
they should
other testimony was that this amendment
would make it near impossible
to replace our aging municipal workforce
and increasingly empty chairs on our
volunteer boards and commissions as
citizens would be fearful of the
potential negative
impact to the community of good faith
decisions
or in new hampshire unlike some other
states
qualified immunity does not mean 100
percent protection
or that employees are not accountable
for their actions
qualified immunity does not mean that
municipal employees are not held
responsible for reckless behavior
or that municipal employees are not
subject to criminal prosecution or tort
liability
under current law they are or that
qualified
immunity protects municipalities from
lawsuits arising from good faith
decisions
not all lawsuits resulting from bad
behaving employees
are from bad behaving employees some are
from
public amenities such as public parks
that are free of charge
that that also benefit from the
protections of qualified immunity
i agree with all this prior testimony
but what you may not know
and what i'd like to talk about today is
how this amendment would devastate
a community like franklin it would put
poorer and small communities at a
disadvantage
and hinder those communities ability to
move forward economically
let me explain franklin is a mill town
we are once a thriving community but
after the last mill mills closed in the
early 70s we have steadily declined
to a revenue star starved property poor
community
over the last five years franklin has
pulled up its bootstraps and put in the
work to reinvent ourselves in a
sustainable way that will bring
economic vitality back to our community
as well as
those communities surrounding us the
results of those efforts are finally
coming to fruition in 2021
as the construction of our white water
kayak venue in the winnipesaukee river
will begin this summer
as many of you have probably heard in
recent news articles
this whitewater kayak park is the first
of its kind
in new england although there are over
300 parks in north america
it will bring a whole new outdoor
recreation economy
imagine the ski industry coming to new
hampshire for the first time
this outdoor recreation economy is based
on
evidence from the other 300 parks show
that will bring over 160
000 visitors to watch those taking part
in the activities in the river those
visitors
mrs milner i don't want to cut you short
we and we appreciate what you're doing
with the water park but if you could
just focus on the amendment that would
be appreciated
yeah i'm getting to that thank you um
so this outdoor park is going to be the
anchor of our outdoor amenities
and it's going to be it's going to be
our revitalization effort to become an
outdoor recreation destination
so we have several outdoor recreation
events in the city they're all free to
the public
this amendment taking away qualified
immunity
from those makes it difficult for us to
continue
along that path of economic development
so qualified immunity allows us to
provide these amenities
which will drive out which will
sorry excuse me bring in our economic
engine and bring vitality back to the
community
franklin simply could not afford any of
this without qualified immunity
although franklin will take pride in
keeping our amenities maintained and
safe for the users there is inherent
risk
in any outdoor recreation activity
qualified immunity protects us
from that risk our little community
pays currently 165 000 per year for
property liability insurance
with qualified immunity in place
recently the city had all of our
insurances
including our property liability
insurance out to quote to ensure the
best rates for the citizens of franklin
franklin does not participate in the
public pool for property liability but
does have a private insurance carrier
so all of the insurances came back with
the exception of property liability
we were told that the potential
elimination of qualified immunity was a
big part of that
bigger communities may be able to afford
the increases in property liability or
judgments
imposed franklin and other communities
like us simply cannot afford to maintain
insurance coverage or afford damages
from potential and likely frivolous
lawsuits
resulting from using our free to the
public amenities that will drive
our revitalization amenities that will
no longer be viable
because the risk may be too high will be
things like the white water kayak park
our ski mountain playgrounds parks ice
skating rinks
trails climbing walls parkour courses
pump tracks beaches
and pavilions just to name a few
these are the things you asked for three
minutes so i
i'm gonna ask you to wrap up if you
would
i'm almost there thank you very much so
these are the things that
this community that is redefining
themselves as an outdoor recreation
needs
this is franklin's future qualified
immunity
is necessary to move forward with this
economic development effort
this proposed amendment will strip
franklin and many other communities of
the things that will make them
communities
and not a place to put your stuff this
proposed amendment will kill franklin's
best shot of economic recovery in the
past 50 years
and make the last five years of our
efforts for naught
please consider the unintended
consequences of this amendment when
voting on this amendment and give
franklin
other communities a chance to thrive
thank you for your time and attention
today
are there questions representative smith
do you have a question
um yes thank you very much mr chair and
i hope you can answer this very briefly
miss milner but are you
saying um that franklin is planning to
do
things that are not responsible
in terms of protecting the best
interests of the city
and of the public and therefore you want
to be
free of any uh responsibility for what
you do no um franklin is committed to
maintaining the best
possible parks um all of our free
amenities and keeping
them thank you very much for that answer
then i
i don't really see the relationship um
between uh this proposed amendment
and uh and and your um
and your testimony but i i do not i
respect the committee's
time and therefore hope that we could
talk about it on
another occasion so we can explore those
views
thank you thank you i do have an example
if you'd like to talk about it
not right now because i think we you
know we try to make sure we hear from as
many people as possible
i'm sure you understand that absolutely
thank you
representative oregon did you have a
question uh
well yeah sure yes first of all uh miss
milner i hope
uh hope whoever there's a shooting
incident in franklin i hope
the gunman or government government is
found soon in the situation resolved but
how how was your situation
as a municipality that's developing a
white water kayaking thing or any other
any other attraction of that sort how
are you different from a
private entrepreneur private if a
private company wanted to start one they
would probably take it for granted that
they would need that they could be sued
if somebody was seriously injured that
they were involved
right so unlike a private entrepreneur
um who would charge a fee and
pay their liability insurance out of
that fee the city of franklin is
providing these amenities free of charge
to the community so um so it makes it a
little bit different than a private
person where you could if you go to a
ski mountain you are paying for that
lift ticket
for sure but in franklin's ski mountain
is a community ski mountain
and there's little to no fee to use it
um okay so what
oh okay i just wondering what the oh so
what's the uh
what sort of the financial uh plan for
it if there's no fees so how is this
being paid for right right so um
our community like i said bootstraps um
we do a lot of fundraising in the
community in order to provide these
amenities
many of our children 60 are free to
reduce lunch in our school district so
we'd like to provide these amenities to
give them something
better to do with their time um so
that's what we do in franklin all right
thank you
thank you for your testimony today ms
milner thank you
and next person would be keith
nealy
thank you mr chair mr neely you asked
for five minutes i'm gonna hold you to
that
okay yes sir i will be as swift as
possible
uh my name is keith neely i'm an
attorney at the institute
for justice ij is a non-profit law firm
that works all over the country to
defend
individual rights and i wanted to
testify today in support of amendment
h to senate bill 96 because it
represents the gold standard
for state civil rights reform and it's
an excellent opportunity for new
hampshire
to continue leading the country in
protecting individual liberties
today i wanted to make uh just three
very swift points the first
is that it's important that
municipalities are held responsible
for the bad actions of their employees
because that's the very same standard
that we apply
every day in the private sector because
we as a society recognize
that employers have a responsibility to
hire
better to train better and to supervise
their employees
and municipalities are no different
representative lynn earlier made
a comment that perhaps it would be best
to hold officers individually liable
but one of the problems with that
approach is that it leaves the victims
of government misconduct to the whims
of the officer's bank account and when
victims
are faced with a constitutional
violation and they go after a
judgment-proof
officer an officer who cannot pay for
the violations that they committed then
the victim is left without an effective
remedy
and that's why municipalities need to be
on the hook for the bad actions of their
employees
the second point i want to make is to
echo what representative burch said in
his opening remarks
which is that the costs of ending
qualified immunity are not inherent to
this legislation
they're inherent to the bad actors in
the system
but i want to make one further point and
that's the fact that these
costs already exist the problem is that
they're being born
by the victims of government misconduct
they're being born by people all over
the state of new hampshire who currently
don't have a remedy when their vit when
their rights excuse me
have been violated and so what this
legislation does is it reapportions
those costs it doesn't create them
it reapportions them to the
organizations and entities within the
state
that are responsible for them
lastly i wanted to respond to a couple
of the earlier comments
that were made first by representative
lynn about reasonableness
uh and and with respect to
representative len i i think he misreads
the plain text of
of this law when he directs the
committee to 507
h4 subpart one a
because that discussion of
reasonableness in the statute pretty
clearly refers to an officer's
subjective
understanding of his activity and what i
mean by that is
is that under this amended law the fact
that an officer subjectively believed
that what he was doing was okay
is no defense because his objective
standard as
the supreme court has has frequently
held in a variety of cases
is is all that matters and so his
concern that
somehow this invocation or excuse me
this this bar
of reasonableness would would lead to
all kinds of a parade of horribles
is uh is frankly unfounded and lastly
i wanted to respond to uh some of the
comments from from the previous speaker
about
the the franklin water park because you
know respectfully i
i think she misunderstands the role of
qualified immunity
because qualified immunity has nothing
to do with negligent slip and fall cases
of the type that you might expect to see
in a public utility like a water park it
has to do with the deprivation of
constitutional rights
and and with respect to the previous
speaker i do not know many water parks
whose
business models are built on the wanton
deprivation of constitutional rights
and if there are any i certainly would
not want to attend such a water park
so with all that said i i respectfully
urge the committee to vote in favor of
amendment 1244
h and i am happy to answer any questions
thank you mr neely representative
alexander do you have a question i do mr
terry thank you
um thank you mr neely for taking my
question um your last example about the
water park how
uh there's no deprivation a
constitutional right are you aware of
in the in the in the amendment there is
also a violation of law
is uh gives warrant for a
a lawsuit or a cost of action as well so
it's not just constitutional rate
well it's the rights privileges or
immunities
secured by those laws so i i would
respectfully
respond that it's not simply a
deprivation of the law
it's a deprivation of a law that creates
a an
individual right and in in prior cases
uh and really throughout this this
nation's entire jurisprudence right
there's
there's been a distinction between
simply a violation of a law and a
violation of a law that was intended to
create
an individual right so again i i don't
believe that
even as this law is currently written
you would see slip and fall cases become
a constitutional tort that's that's not
what the language
as i understand it that's not what the
language of of this amendment would do
thank you are there any other questions
for mr neely
mr chair yes representative
question thank you mr chair uh attorney
neely
uh you said you represent uh plaintiffs
around the country do you currently
or have you or have you been contacted
by anybody from the state of new
hampshire
to represent them in any
of these type of cases
uh no sir i have not
yeah any other questions for mr neely
thank you for your testimony today thank
you mr chair
uh kyle aspinwall
you're there can you raise your hand mr
aspen
good morning can i be heard sir you may
excellent thank you very very much um
good morning and thank you
chairman gordon and to the members of
the house judiciary committee
for allowing me to provide testimony
relative to amendment 1244-h
for sb96 and just a quick moment of
housekeeping
um i got a little confused in terms of
signing up for
testimony this morning i show opposition
which
i am in opposition as i'll get to for
the amendment but not
for sb 96 the bill so i hope that that's
clear
just at our hearing this morning we are
just addressing the
amendment excellent okay very good thank
you
you did ask for five minutes yes i did
and thank you very much
um so speaking plainly and from the
heart and as eloquently as i can muster
at this hour of the morning
um i wanted to speak a little bit about
the leact members
um who put forth the original bill
as we're moving towards uh through the
conversation about the amendment
we formed a bit of a breakfast club we
had a general
a deputy general a department of safety
chair
we had standards in training providing
information for
what police officers should aspire to we
had a leader from the council on
diversity and inclusion
we had a president from the naacp one of
the oldest civil rights
organizations in the country we had a
justice of the court
we had rank and file police officers
represented we had the chiefs of police
if new hampshire represented
we had mental illness and organization
represented we had a smart justice
organizer who is
con who is dedicated to
justice reform we had a public defender
we also had at this point he is now the
assistant commissioner of safety
and one of the first african-americans
put in that position
in the history of new hampshire if i'm
not mistaken
we also had another community organizer
and then there's me
my day job is the executive director for
the human rights commission
new hampshire's oldest civil rights
organization and
led by me a third generation civil
rights worker
these are our bona fides and with all of
that
we were courageous in our efforts to put
feelings aside
and look at facts from a myriad of
perspectives and you
legislators must be courageous also you
show up for people and do the tough
stuff
and as the resident thread puller i have
a question
several questions for you today is
sliding language from a bill that was
previously laid on the table
courageous is the obfuscation of months
of hard work and consensus building
to create sb 96 courageous and possibly
killing this bill
with a decidedly short-sighted attempt
at vainglory is that courageous
i would say not on this day now
i am very respectful of each of you and
this legislative process
even though it can be very frustrating
however i am extremely disheartened
at the repudiation etched into the
language of amendment 1244-h
i would also ask that this body of which
i include the sponsors of the amendment
are to vote itl on said amendment and
allow
sb 96 to proceed forth a conversation
about the actual content of 1244-h
can be had again just not in this way
not with this bill and not in this
session
with that i close my testimony and thank
you all very much for being truly
courageous in advance
by helping all state inc employees of
which i am one
by voting this amendment itl i am very
happy to answer any questions
that may be uh had from the committee
thank you
are there any questions for ms malachi
cnn thank you for your courageous
testimony
and the uh
next person to testify will be brandon
deposer
yes hi this is brandon del posa can you
hear me
yes we can't hear you thank you you
didn't you did ask for five minutes
yeah thank you um so thank you for
having me uh my name is brandon del pozo
i am a postdoctoral fellow in substance
use research at brown university what
brings me to your
proceedings today is i served 23 years
as a
police officer 19 years in the new york
city police department
and four years as the chief of police of
burlington vermont
i don't take coming to a state where i
did not work as a police officer to
offer testimony lightly
but i will say by way of my interest and
affinity for new hampshire what brought
me here today
i attended college in new hampshire i
lived in new hampshire
i served in the new hampshire army
national guard is a infantry officer in
your fabled mountain warfare unit
uh and i've hiked all of the uh 48 4 000
footers so this is a state whose uh
proceedings and laws and and goings-on
matter matter very much to me
um i'm testifying today
in support of the amendment as a police
officer and former chief of police
for a handful of reasons that i'd like
to offer some perspective on
the first is as a retired chief of
police i'm currently
named in three federal lawsuits i'm
dealing with them and i will be dealing
with them for the next three years
um i don't find that to be an enjoyable
situation i find it to be
stressful but i do acknowledge that
citizens have the recourse to bring suit
and i know that i am indemnified as
having liability for the
outcomes of those suits based on the
fact that it was part and parcel with my
uh official duties
now my brother and this is relevant to
qualified immunity
was an attorney he's a former prosecutor
for the new york county da's office he's
also
a an employee of the new york state
attorney general he filed an amicus
brief on a very notable
qualified immunity case tolan v cotton
that went to the united states supreme
court in 2014.
um his amicus brief and his writings
were cited in in the court's decision
and it really had an effect in my
opinion on um
qualified immunity this was a case where
um
tolan was in a car he owned going to a
house he lived in
with his mother when an officer
misentered the license plate
thought his car was stolen and
approached him in his own driveway with
his brother and his mother
all of whom were unarmed held them at
gunpoint and when the mother became
indignant saying this is my car
these are my sons i live here why are
you pointing a gun at me nobody's armed
the officer went hands on with the
mother toll and cursed and said get the
f off my mom and rose up from the ground
he was shot it ended his career in
professional baseball he was ascending
to that his father was a major league
baseball player
it had a permanent effect on his health
and for him
and his family to get any redress at all
for being in their own driveway with
their own car
in front of their own home unarmed just
going about their business completely
innocent of any wrongdoing whatsoever
because a police officer entered a
license plate wrong thought the worst
held them at gunpoint end up shooting
one of them
for them to get any recourse they had to
take their case to the united states
supreme court
because of qualified immunity and the
idea that citizens have to take their
case in some cases to the u.s supreme
court
to get any redress for egregious
misconduct just struck me as wrong
and my brother's legal work in that
regard which i follow changed my opinion
on the breadth of qualified immunity it
is not necessarily a terrible idea
the idea that police should be immune
from certain frivolous lawsuits
but the way case law has prevailed has
made it over broad
and overreaching and foreclosed
legitimate citizens claims to get
civil redress for substantial acts of
police misconduct
and i remind and one of the moving
things when i was here last week
um listening to the testimony before it
was moved to this week was
to listen to new hampshire police
officers talk about their passion for
their careers
their passion for public safety the idea
to that they need to
have some leeway to do their jobs well
um i'm tremendously sympathetic to them
i have tremendous admiration for any
police officer working in today's
environment
and i have immense respect for the uh uh
for new hampshire law enforcement um and
this is not to discredit them in any way
i do feel that municipalities to train
well hire well
hold their officers accountable for
misconduct set the right standards
will not feel an appreciable change
between
the situation that exists now for them
and the situation that would exist if
you were able to bring
civil suit at the state level to get
redress for police misconduct
so that having been said thank you for
uh this opportunity to speak and i'd be
happy to answer any questions
thank you are there any questions from
mr poso yes representative alexander
thank you mr chair and thank you uh mr
caposo for taking my question
um can you describe a little bit more um
into the
reasons why you left the burlington
police department
so yeah i left the burlington police
department because when the
um when when the city council was a
democratic so
you know bernie sanders for example
lives in burlington it's a very
left-leaning city
uh even as a very progressive police
officer i was seen by
uh many people on the far left as some
sort of right-leaning so i was a cop i
could do no right
i had an excellent relationship with the
community uh
until um the socialists took over the
city council when the progressive party
which is a socialist party
took over the city council they decided
to try to disarm my police officers
reduce the size of my police department
they said that 40
of my police officers were domestic
abusers and i reacted poorly to that
there was a city critic
who i trolled on twitter anonymously
i was frustrated by the way my cops in
the city were being treated by the
socialists among us
i took on bridge to that and i did what
many many many many citizens have done i
said
anonymously this is for example um
the people who ignore you have
antibodies that the rest of us should
clone because
it would be very valuable to not have to
pay attention to a person like you
i said that on twitter anonymously when
the news found out i first denied it
and then i said i will tell the truth
the next time i'm asked i did
and there was a scandal that a chief of
police used twitter to criticize
somebody anonymously
at that point i was into two interviews
to be the police commissioner of
philadelphia
i was also on the final interview to be
the head of police
philanthropy for a major philanthropy
organization and my mayor said this is a
tremendous fight
the socialists have their knives out i
can invest in your career
but you've already applied to other jobs
so i resigned
does that does that make sense is that
um does that answer your question uh
representative alexander
it does i just have a quick follow up um
thank you so um in new hampshire rsa i
believe it is
if i cite it right hold on i just want
to pull the card rsa 31 colon 104
it describes a cause of action that
citizens can use against a police
officer
who quote does wanton or reckless uh
misconduct
so in your uh personal capacity would
you qualify that situation with the
license plate
as a want or reckless uh misconduct
police officer that would actually be a
cause of action existing in the state
no not the license plate per se but the
the gunfire
uh you could you could if the person is
unarmed
um if the person is standing up that
there's no indication that there's an
imminent threat
which is again a matter to litigate
right i'm not going to go back and
litigate on those particular facts
but shooting an unarmed person in their
own driveway in their own home when
there's no weapons in their hand
like that could seem like something that
would be a cause of action
thank you any other questions
for mr del pozo
yes representative trott here thank you
mr chair
mr deposo a quick question you said you
were from vermont did they have
qualified i'm going to be there
um so no right now vermont there's no
when you say they have qualified
immunity qualified
because we're considering it as a
federal uh doctrine
so it applies federally if you're asking
if they had a state recourse no they
don't have a state recourse
thank you any other questions from mr
del pozo
see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
john krepsky
need to raise your hand mr trufsky so we
can see you
did you find it
mr chairman mate can you hear me uh we
can hear you
you you asked for three minutes mr krebs
yes and i'll i'll try to adhere to that
to the best i can
i'll try to hold you to that good
morning mr chairman
um and members of the committee thank
you for allowing me to testify
i'm here on behalf of the new hampshire
police association
and we are against the amendment
for a variety of reasons um we
initially testified in support of sp 96
but if this amendment is adopted we
cannot and will not
support sb 96 or the amendment
we're against the uh amendment for
policy reasons
because we believe as it's currently
written it will impair contracts
in violation of the federal and state
constitution three that the
um name of the bill of creating a cause
of action a cause of action already
exists
that it treats public policy public
employees disparately not only
police officers there are language
problems with the bill
and it encourages the proliferation
of litigation um i believe that the
policy reasons have been articulated
um in previous testimony um most among
them
is the inability of government to
conduct itself in a reasonable manner
and would
deter and there would be a loss of
productivity in the operations of
government
i think that the policy reasons are
implicitly recognized
in this amendment because the amendment
actually adopts and retains uh
so-called official immunity for
judiciary and legislative immunity
and that's at um section 507
h4 roman numeral 3 and page
it would be also being located on page 2
lines 20-22 um it seems to me that the
bill or the amendment as it's
constituted
recognizes the importance of the policy
considerations
for the legislative and judicial
functions but excludes
the individuals who are required to
enforce
those edicts from having any immunity
we think that's fundamentally unfair
number two we believe that it impairs
contract
um as an illegal impairment of contract
i believe that the uh justice lynn spoke
to that at length
but i do point you to section 507
h6 which is at page two lines 35-38
um in that it specifically says
um that notwithstanding any provision of
law contract
or agreement to the contrary an
individual may be
fired for a um
a violation of any constitutional rights
think of the unfairness of this um
because in a collective bargaining
agreement or other
uh contract that is provided a just
cause clause often
is contained therein which requires an
employer
to meet a seven-point test it is now
eliminates that important provision that
impairment would be
an impairment of the contractual
relationships it would impair the
uh relationship and it would be
substantial as
is recognized by the courts um
in that regard for the other reasons
stated by judge lynn which i'm
trying to go through this quickly to fit
within the three minutes
we would also adopt those arguments
the access to the courts already exists
i think that was set forth by judge lynn
but i also point
the uh the committee to um
507 b which provides for access for
bodily injuries for municipalities
42 u.s city 1983 for constitutional
excuse me federal constitutional
violations
and 541b which allows for recovery
for uh bad actions of the state in fact
that's recognized
um by the uh the bill when it
says at the top that it uh it supersedes
507b 541b
etc um and that's at page one
lines 15 through 18.
we also believe that it um treats public
employees disparately
for example it would
there is legislative immunity and
immunity for judicious actions judiciary
actions
um contained within the bill or the
amendment at 507 h4
think about it from this perspective
it's not just police officers
but imagine a assistant clerk who's in a
town
enforcing a voting rights bill that has
been passed
operating good faith in trying to
enforce the law would create liability
for that municipality
and possibly the termination of that
employee because it is later found to be
unconstitutional
that employee is following the
directives of the
legislative body whether it be local or
statewide
and is fired and in this amendment
it actually says that the good faith
reliance by the
um employee can no longer be used as a
defense
thank you the language is also
problematic
can you can you wrap up attorney we we
believe the language is problematic
because
it refers to state agents agents and
government agents
without a definition of either one which
means that this law may be applied
apparently on the different levels
and um we we also believe
that with this would have many negative
implications
uh thank you for uh listening to my
testimony um
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
that are outstanding i tried to be as
quick as i could sir
didn't it was appreciated any questions
for attorney krebsky
yeah representative trottier thank you
mr chair
upstate quick question for you testified
that
if all of a sudden the legislative
branch
passes a law and a police officer acts
upon that law
under good faith and it goes to court
and the court finds that it is
unconstitutional
um can that officer still be charged
or you know um be sued tracked in good
fate
yes um and because of that uh i point
you directly to the
amendment um at page two lines uh
sixteen through seventeen which says
that uh the court shall not be impeded
by if the state agent acted in good
faith
or that the state agent believed
reasonably or otherwise that his actions
were lawful at the time
thank you any other questions for
attorney
thanks for your testimony today thank
you
the next person is jerry g
asks for four minutes
uh good morning are you able to hear me
we we can hear you um we do keep a
record do you mind
sharing your last name as well with us i
i
uh i'm sorry that i uh that i registered
as that it was it was a mistake
uh thank you my name is jerry greenfield
thank you and good morning distinguished
members of the judiciary committee
as i said i'm jerry greenfield i'm the
co-founder of ben
jerry's ice cream and i'm also the
co-chair
of the campaign to end qualified
immunity
a national coalition of business leaders
professional athletes lawyers
former law enforcement agents advocacy
groups
and concerned citizens dedicated to
holding cops accountable
i'm here today to express my support for
the amendment
ben and i both know that in the business
world
accountability is the key to achieving
results
this is even more critical with all
government employees
especially law enforcement officers
who we pay to protect and serve us
and authorize to use lethal force for
our safety
the vast majority of public servants and
police officers take this mission
seriously serving their communities with
dedication
and kindness but there are bad actors
too
those who abuse their power and bring
harm to others
the supreme court dismissed the need to
hold these bad
actors accountable when they established
the doctrine of qualified immunity
effectively giving government employees
the ability to violate our civil rights
without repercussions
and we've seen how this unfair and
unjust policy is used
especially by bad cops
accountability is not a burden to bear
it's an opportunity to build a better
government
it's an opportunity to retrain and
uplevel
government employees it's an opportunity
to attract high qualified candidates who
are committed to service
and it's an opportunity to create a
culture of excellence
that will yield dividends for
generations to come
if you want to build public trust in
policing and public institutions
honor and support good law enforcement
agents and tireless public employees
and respect the civil rights of new
hampshire residents
you have to support this amendment to
end the unjust doctrine
of qualified immunity thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
questions for mr greenfield
seeing that again thank you for your
testimony today
thank you cordell
johnson
yes
okay thank you mr chairman of cordell
johnston
representing the new hampshire municipal
association in opposition to this
amendment
uh first of all i want to i want to
thank representative burch i think
it was me he was referring to as the nhm
a
lobbyist who is i think it's he said a
kind and thoughtful person
um i think he is also a kind and
thoughtful person
uh and i probably agree with him more
often than i disagree with him
and i look forward to uh
to sharing our bourbon recipes again
when this is over
um i do need to correct something he
said though
he said that the municipal association
similarly opposed
the taxpayer taxpayer standing bill
three years ago
claiming that it would lead to an
explosion of litigation
we did not oppose taxpayer standing
there were people who did
uh and they did make that claim but we
did not
we in fact worked on that we didn't
support it but we didn't oppose it
either
um so i just wanted to clarify that but
this bill is different
uh this this really is a problem and
and let me be clear about this we do not
have any argument with the proposition
that government actors
whether it's police or anyone else ought
to be accountable for obvious misconduct
and in almost all cases at least in new
hampshire they already
are uh citing a few cases from other
states
uh doesn't change that and uh note that
i think we've heard from four
witnesses other than the uh sponsor in
support of this bill
three of whom were from outside new
hampshire i think
i would encourage the committee to
listen to new hampshire voices on this
bill
but if you want to pass a law that that
does provide more assurance of
accountability for bad
actors we can get behind that and and
we're even happy to work on it
uh and representative lin suggested the
same thing
but that's not what this bill does this
bill makes local governments liable
for innocent mistakes by good actors
and for things that aren't even mistakes
just uh differing interpretations of the
law
and i could give you uh dozens of
examples of situations that
where this could come up but i'll i'll
just give you one
i'm the moderator in my town and by the
way someone said that this bill protects
all elected officials it does not
it protects legislative officials but
but
not all elected officials so at our town
meeting
somebody gets disruptive so i have a
police officer escort him out of the
building
and detain him until the end of the
meeting which the law
gives me the the authority to do
he sues me and he sues the police
officer
for violating his first and fourth
amendment rights
and the judge agrees now under current
law
these are the kinds of good faith
decisions that
that the police officer and i would be
protected from
uh uh government actors have to make
these decisions
decisions every day and they're
protected
but this bill would eliminate that
protection yeah i don't get sued
personally
but the town is is now subject to
liability
for damages and for um
attorney fees where i where i and the
police officer have just followed
a reasonable interpretation of the law
as i said i could come up with dozens of
other examples and i have in some of my
correspondence
so if there are changes that that need
to be made to tighten up the
accountability for
actual misconduct
for intentional misconduct by whether
it's police officers or others
as i said we're happy to work on that
but to take
take a sledgehammer to the entire system
to get rid of qualified immunity
is is not the answer so i very strongly
encourage you to uh reject this
amendment
thank you very much are there any
questions for mr johnson
see none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you jay schweiker
thank you can you hear me again thank
you very much my name is
jay schweikert and i am a research
fellow with the cato institute
uh and my uh focus for the last three
and a half years has been the doctrine
of qualified immunity
um and that doctrine is obviously at the
center of these discussions today but i
think it would be helpful to provide
a little bit more background and
explanation on exactly
how this doctrine works in practice uh
and what eliminating it would and would
not mean
as long as you can do that in the five
minutes you've asked absolutely
absolutely um so the the key
feature of qualified immunity that
actually hasn't been
is the clearly established law standard
the way that qualified immunity works is
if someone's constitutional
rights have been violated um a
a plaintiff to get relief for that
violation also has to show that that
right was quote
clearly established at the time of the
violation
and in practice what that means is that
they have to find
a prior judicial decision in their
jurisdiction
with functionally identical facts as
their own case
what this means is that although we've
been discussing concepts like
reasonableness and good faith
uh qualified immunity actually has
nothing to do with reasonableness or
good faith
the only thing that matters with this
doctrine
is whether the law was clearly
established which again
generally means whether there were
sufficiently similar facts in prior
judicial decisions
so just to give a couple examples of
this uh in the case
jessup versus city of fresno which
representative burch touched on in his
opening comments
uh the court granted immunity to
officers who were alleged to have stolen
over 200 and over 200 000 in cash and
rare coins
while executing a search warrant uh they
received qualified immunity not because
they were acting in good faith of course
they weren't acting in good
faith they received immunity simply
because that court had not yet
issued a decision addressing that exact
question
uh similarly in a recent decision called
fraser versus evans
uh police officers uh violated the man's
first amendment rights by illegally
searching
and threatening to arrest him for
recording them in public something that
he had a first amendment right to do
and these officers had been explicitly
trained
uh that citizens do have a first
amendment right
to record the police in public they knew
they were violating this man's rights
but they received immunity because while
six of the federal circuit courts had
had explicitly addressed this question
the one particular court where this
occurred
the 10th circuit had not so in other
words
this doctrine turns entirely on the
happenstance
of the fact patterns of prior cases not
on whether a defendant was acting
reasonably or in good way
another misconception of qualified
immunity that i want to address
is that it has nothing to do with
deterring frivolous lawsuits
um a frivolous lawsuit by its very
nature is one that is not meritorious
either whether it's factually
unsupported or legally unsupported
but qualified immunity only matters it
only does work
in the instance where someone's rights
have been violated
but where a court determines that those
rights were not clearly established
so for qualified immunity to make the
difference in a case
it must necessarily mean that the case
was not frivolous that there was a
meritorious claim
when cases are genuinely frivolous there
are other tools of civil procedure that
are perfectly capable of dismissing
those suits
so whether or not frivolous lawsuits or
frivolous civil rights
lawsuits are a problem it's just not
something that qualified immunity is
geared to address
and finally i want to briefly touch on
this question of state law remedies
um and just to explain why state law
remedies are not an adequate alternative
to a robust civil rights law for
addressing constitutional violations
and there are two main reasons one is
simply that uh
most state law remedies uh do not
include attorneys fees um
and now you know uh judge lynn i believe
you know recognized that he might
support attorneys fees but
more generally without attorneys fees
most civil rights plaintiffs are simply
not going to be able to bring a case at
all
but additionally although there is some
overlap between state law remedies and
constitutional violations
it's by no means complete there are all
kinds of constitutional violations
violations of free speech and freedom of
religion by uh racial discrimination
due pro trial rights uh and many others
that simply cannot be redressed through
traditional
court law remedies and that's why a
robust civil rights law
is essential uh and with that i'm happy
to answer any questions
are there any questions for mr
schweikert
cnn thank you for your testimony today
it's greg martakos
you are there raise your hand so we can
see you
let's see
mark bowden
well mr bowden good morning
uh mr chair person thank you for uh
taking my testimony and thank you to the
house judiciary committee for allowing
me to speak today
no problem you asked for two minutes
i'm going to be very quick my name is
mark beaudoin i'm a retired
sergeant from the new hampshire state
police i'm currently the executive
director of the new hampshire troopers
association
uh we are in support of sb 96 for the
lee act
but we are against uh the amendment uh
that is brought forward by
representative burch
um we believe that this is a this is a
national narrative that is being pushed
on the state of
lecture i think you've heard many people
today testifying they're all from a good
chunk of them are from out of state that
are in support of this
this is a solution looking for a problem
none of them have mentioned any issues
that have been going on in new hampshire
as to why this
desperate change needs to be made
we are also experiencing a recruitment
and retention issue here
in new hampshire with our law
enforcement although we try very hard to
recruit the very best
we're finding that to be more and more
difficult as time goes on
currently as you heard from a lot of the
other people that testified in
opposition uh to this amendment
bad actors are held accountable there is
a way to hold them accountable
currently through current law so public
employee sectors
don't get 100 immunity all right if they
act in a reckless a wanton manner
they can be held accountable for civil
suits
this is a uh and speaking as
a citizen and as a resident of new
hampshire i am also concerned about some
of the things that the municipalities
brought forward
i pay a hefty property tax already
i don't need my taxes going up as a
result of this whether it's through
insurance costs
or lawsuits and as many of you know
a lot of these lawsuits are settled with
nuisance money
which will add up after a while and it's
the public that will be paying for that
so i'm not going to reiterate a lot of
uh what was already testified
to we are in opposition of this bill we
don't feel that this is good for new
hampshire we don't feel it's right for
new hampshire
but we don't see that new hampshire is
it currently experiencing a problem with
this
and that there would be a lot of
unintended consequences as a result
and with that i thank you for uh
listening to my testimony
and uh if anyone has any questions i'd
be happy to answer them
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for the boat
cigna again thank you for your testimony
ken norton
who asked for one minute
good morning chairman gordon and
committee members my name is ken norton
i'm the executive director of nami new
hampshire the national alliance on
mental illness
and i was one of the 14 members in the
leak commission
and i would echo the testimony by my
colleague on
malachi in opposing this amendment
i take no position on the content of the
amendment itself
but i would just contrast the hearing
last week
on senate bill 96 itself where there was
almost
uh complete unanimity in support of
the bill itself with this morning's
hearing with the controversy
regarding the amendment and i think it
would be uh
shameful if we jeopardized the contents
of
senate bill 96 by trying to attach this
amendment
to it which should which should have its
own hearing so
i would ask you to vote this amendment
uh to
inexpedient to legislate and i'm happy
to answer any questions
thank you representative alexander um
thank you mr chair thank you
mr norton for taking my question um
would you classify this amendment
as a poison pill on the work that the
commission did it
for a police catholic
um thank you for your question no i i
mean i i think it's
well intended i understand why this is
important for us to have a conversation
about it in new hampshire i i actually
liked um
representative lynn's suggestion that
perhaps this should be a study committee
i just don't believe that it should be
attached to
this bill thank you any other questions
for mr norton seeing them thank you for
your testimony today
thank you michael satar
good morning good morning
we can hear you fine good morning
chairman gordon and members of the house
judiciary committee
my name is michael cetar and i offer
this testimony
as the president of the new hampshire
association of fire chiefs
i also serve as the fire chief for the
towns of tilton
and northfield as a quick background the
new hampshire association of fight
chiefs provides leadership
education and advocacy for the new
hampshire fire service
the new hampshire fire chiefs
association are opposed to the proposed
amendment
as you know many communities in new
hampshire rely on call firefighters as
first responders
a recent article from the concord
monitor highlighted the challenges
communities are having
to find individuals willing to serve as
call firefighters
full-time departments are experiencing
the same challenges
if sb-96 were to become law with the
proposed amendment
those who are willing to serve their
local communities as call firefighters
or could those who consider a career in
the fire service
may decide against doing so to avoid the
associated
new potential for being the subject of a
high profile lawsuit
which could result in their termination
new hampshire full-time and call fire
departments must compete with the
private sector
for employers as well as departments in
other states
creating an environment which makes new
hampshire less attractive
will only exacerbate these problems
the new hampshire association of fire
chiefs opposes the approach
amendment and ask you to do so as well
we have submitted our comments in
writing for your reference and i thank
you for your time this morning i'd be
happy to answer any questions
thank you chief uh are there questions
for chief cetera
seeing that again thank you for your
testimony today
welcome attorney richard head
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
we can hear you fine
excellent thank you um for the record my
name is richard head i'm the government
affairs coordinator for the judicial
branch
we do not take any opposition on the
policy
of this amendment um i do have already
started with one request actually based
on the testimony have
two requests and i know in
a u.s supreme court opinion that
expanded the the
1983 coverage in federal lawsuits
a dissent from justice powell that said
no one can foresee the number of new
filings in our already overburdened
courts
but nobody can doubt the consequences
that it will be substantial
my first request this relates to the
fact that house bill 111 did not have a
fiscal note
is that if this bill is ultimately
supported by this committee that would
be referred
to the lba for this if you want to lie
i think it would be useful for the house
to have information
with regard to the potential fiscal
impacts and we certainly do not take a
position
on the policy but we do believe that
there will be an increase in the number
of lawsuits filed
and that will have an impact on the
resources of the court
and we would potentially be looking for
resources that might cover that either
now or down the road so i do think it
would be useful and instructive
for the legislative branch my second
request
it relates to the testimony and i uh
i understand that the the focus of this
has been on qualified immunity and i
just point to
um page 1 lines 30 to 32 of the bill
and suggest and again have no policy uh
opinion or view on on how this might
turn out but suggest perhaps a
referral to the attorney general as to
the scope of what this means
because it does say an individual may
seek legal equitable
or other relief under this chapter in
state court
for an injury caused by an agent of the
state of new hampshire or political
subdivision
in violation of a right under the laws
or constitution of the state of new
hampshire or the united states
and i do think it might be useful
especially from my perspective in
putting together a fiscal note
as to whether or not that phrasing
expands
the scope of this bill beyond qualified
and again whether or not it does is not
something that
we are complying with
and i thank you for your your time i'd
be happy to answer any questions
thank you are there any questions for
our attorney ahead
sing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
kirk beede
good morning my name is kirk biatti i'm
the fire chief for the city of laconia
and i'm also the first vice president
for the new hampshire association of
fire chiefs
and i'm here speaking in opposition to
the amendment for senate bill 96.
as chief seatar stated uh the new
hampshire association of fire chiefs did
send out a letter
uh um in our opposition
i just want to make a couple quick
points i know it's been a long morning
i'm going to keep it very very short for
you um
we're not looking to protect i think
these are two key points number one is
we're not looking to protect
nor do we support reckless and wanton
actions
what we do want to ensure is that
firefighters emts
and agencies we oversee both an
emergency and a non-emergency response
are not subject to unnecessary
litigation
we believe that the current new
hampshire laws strikes that right
balance
i told you i'd keep it very short i
think those are key points
um thank you for your time this morning
thank you very much chief are there any
questions
for chief biatti
thank you again thank you the
next person is thomas mullins
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee
i understand you can hear me at this
point is that correct we can hear you
fine
yes thank you my name is uh tom mullins
thomas mullins i'm the city attorney
for the city of keene uh speaking on
behalf of our city council who
asked me to attend the meeting i did ask
for three minutes and i promise there
will be three
real people minutes and not lawyer
minutes as a bailiff once said to me
keep it short um in short uh yeah i'm in
favor of the testimony that you've heard
in opposition to
the amendment uh in particular uh
lynn representative lin's comment
you know respective respected first in
the state and
these comments were right on a couple of
real world applications for you first we
think it's the
amendment sweeps way too broadly you've
heard those comments that
with all due respect to the police
officers who have a terrible and
difficult job it's not just directed at
the police officers it applies to all
of our employees and in a couple of real
world consequences
for example we now have a lot of rsa 91a
requests
91a is a statute that arises under our
state constitution
so it is a sort of constitutional right
that's provided
our supreme court uh recently decided
that personnel records and files
uh are no longer sort of per se exempt
so we have to do a privacy analysis to
make a determination as to
whether or not those files should be
released uh if we
are wrong uh and guess wrong and the jur
the judge uh decides that
we were wrong then uh potentially there
was a violation of a law that arises
from a constitutional right committed by
a city agent uh which would make that
individual
uh not the individual libel but the
municipality libel so
uh that we think that just sweeps too
broadly uh the second point i'd like to
make is
you know we've talked a lot about the
1983 action qualified immunity
this is a state law that we're talking
about but it doesn't prevent a plaintiff
from
going into federal court uh seeking 1983
damages
against the individual agent even though
the state law does not provide
for that so we would urge you at this
point to
uh to not uh to itl
uh this amendment um i'm also finally
not going to say to you that we don't
think that there are some issues with
qualified immunity you've heard some of
those
already those probably need to be
addressed
i work with very professional people who
are very well trained
but we all make mistakes and basically
what this amendment does is punish state
city employees for making good faith
mistakes
so on that note mr chairman and members
of the committee i'm happy to answer any
questions but otherwise please
note our opposition to the amendment and
request that it be itl
thank you thank you are there
any questions for mr mullen attorney
mullens
seeing then thank you again for your
testimony the last person who
pre-registered to testify is matthew
broadhead
good morning chairman uh can you hear me
we can
uh thank you chairman and thank you
members of the committee
for working on this important issue and
on this important underlying bill
sb96 my name is matthew broadhead i'm a
senior assistant attorney general
here at the department of justice i am
the bureau chief of the transportation
bureau um but i'm actually appearing
today
on behalf of the attorney general john
carmella and all state agencies
and we do oppose the
uh amendment we do support the
underlying bill
sb96 the original language was based on
consensus
this inserts uh a issue that's
non-germane to what was trying to be
accomplished
by the original language of sd 96
i can't overstate that the original bill
was built on consensus
and had included support from the law
enforcement community as well as
community stakeholders
and uh this kind of risks torpedoing
what uh progress we can make um on
police reform and needed transparency
um so we oppose on that ground uh we
also
without taking a position on the
overarching policy
we do oppose the language of the
amendment because
it uh i think a
previous person testified that it takes
a sledgehammer
we think you know it takes a hatchet to
our statutory scheme
where a scalpel would be more
appropriate
um and and if i i don't want to echo
you know you know or repeat what's
already been discussed but we also
share the same concerns that justin lynn
former justice lynn representative right
now
had testified to in terms of qualified
immunity as a creature of federal law
there are other immunities under state
law that are
that this bill would appear to override
and i just going to list them off
because they're found in rsa
541b and rsa 99d
and if the members of the committee are
not familiar with these
immunities that would now be waived then
i
recommend this issue for further study
so that you can familiarize yourself
with these issues to determine whether
or not uh as a matter of policy you
would want to waive them
they include discretionary function
immunity recreational community
prosecutorial community do care immunity
uh those are that's that's a a statute
that says that state employee can't be
liable if they're
exercising due care in the and
exercising their statutorily obligated
functions which you all set
um intentional toward immunity eleventh
amendment immunity this would wave
uh 11th amendment immunity that the
state enjoys
in federal court which basically serve
as a buttress that
any claims against the state
are not decided by a federal judge in
federal court
they're decided by state judges and
state courts closer to the community
that we serve
that's an important policy decision to
make so if you're not familiar with the
issues i think
commend that for further study um
further
uh now rsa99d gives the state the option
to
whether or not to uh represent a state
employee
who's acted recklessly or wanted
in in with regard to their duties
and that does create personal
accountability for
uh state employees if they are wet one
or
or reckless and uh
therefore the the um
it doesn't have a perverse effect waving
that would have a perverse effect in
that
those uh employees are free to do what
they want
and knowing that they'll be fully
defended and indemnified
um so that i think is concerning there's
also a statutory cap
on damages with respect to the state so
that the budget doesn't get impacted by
a flood of
claims there's a 500 475
000 cap on damages so it doesn't affect
uh the bottom line or the functioning of
government
um this would wait so
there's other drafting issues uh but
i'll just leave it at that i'm happy to
take
questions um i i do if i may
mr chair just want to correct one this
uh perception about what qualified
immunity is in federal court um
there was a somebody from the cato
institute who i think misquoted
the case law in the first circuit which
is governed with governs new hampshire
you don't need to prove that there's a
spitting image case that's a
there's a case it's called velcido v
decker the case that i argued at the
first circuit
and you don't to to to prevail on
qualified immunity you don't need to
show that there's a case a prior case on
point
um that's exactly factually the same
you they don't general they don't
generalize it that
at that level of specific specificity
[Music]
you just you don't need to show that
it's a spitting image
it protects all but the plainly
incompetent
or those who act intentionally so it
protects
officers who make bad guesses in gray
areas
not intentional or incompetent
so that that's all uh i'll leave it at
that and i'm having to take any
questions thank you
thank you attorney broadhead any
questions
see none again thank you for your
testimony
again that includes the people who
pre-registered to testify
today there are some hands up i see
there are four hands up
one no name no last name but
named jeb
good morning mr chairman
yes nice to have it it's nice to have a
unique name
um i apologize for not i didn't think
i'd have a chance to testify this
morning giving hearings
going on in the senate um
as i said last week in the hearing on
the underlying bill i think that there
would be a
significant problem if this
amendment were attached to senate bill
and come over to the senate not having
had the chance to have a hearing
that would be a problem i agree with the
testimony of many witnesses
i've only heard a few of them but i in
particular agree with
the points articulated by cordell
johnson of the municipal association
that what the amendment tries to do
is solve a problem that does not exist
in new hampshire there's no identified
new hampshire problem i think you've
heard significant testimony about the
stress
that it would place through unnecessary
litigation
on all new hampshire towns but in
particular on the people that protect us
our police and our firefighters so i
hope
you reject the amendment and pass the
underlying bill
thank you mr chairman thank you are
there any questions for senator bradley
saying thank you for your testimony
today thank you
robert quinn good afternoon sir can you
hear me
we can hear you fine oh great i'll just
take 60 seconds and i apologize for not
pre-registering
um thank you for having me on robert
quinn for the record
i'm the commissioner of the department
of safety uh we have seven divisions
which include not only the state police
embedded in the state police or the
campus police the marine patrol officers
we have the fire marshal's office the
fire academy homeland security and
emergency management our mission is to
make new hampshire the safest state in
the nation with the highest quality of
life
for all um i just want to say um a lot's
been said today
and what i would like to just kind of
emphasize
is this when new hampshire
um responded to events that were
happening
um around the country we looked
um at making new hampshire law
enforcement kind of the leaders
and in transparency and training and
accountability
i will just echo that we we met for 26
times and when you use the word
consensus we listened to the public
we had a a diverse group on that
league commission we worked very hard
and we reached consensus on
48 items that i think really move us
forward in training community engagement
accountability hiring issues recruitment
i mean we looked at this thing
and we worked very hard i oppose this
because although i support the sb 96 and
all that's in it
i want to see us continue to move
forward when we act ended
to this day we continue to work very
hard on implementing those changes
improving the training improving how we
hire
uh and just making positive movement on
the lee act recommendations so
uh not only um as as commissioner's
safety
but as a member of the league community
i oppose this
um i think there are other opportunities
just to study this
issue but i do not want to
put us backwards and i think that's what
this would do
so i'm happy to answer any question
thank you for uh
allowing me to raise my hand and jump in
judge
thank you commissioner yes
representative trottier
thank you mr chair um commissioner quinn
just one quick question
when new hampshire started seeing a
problem across the country
you're saying the hampshire took a
proactive approach
to deal with these type of issues in new
hampshire before they started to happen
i i believe we did and um i think that
if i would encourage everyone to look at
the the document
what what leaked looked at we addressed
and i think we're forward-leaning and
quite honestly i i think we have a great
culture that recognizes mistakes
you know uh do occur but we need to
uh provide the best training the best
resources
and uh and and i will say this there are
challenges today that you know i did not
face when i get hired in 1985 as a state
trooper
and we have to continually improve and
enhance
and that is what the leact commission
did and and i would say yes and i would
put that
you know that that that product you know
up against anything that's been done and
i
i encourage everybody to read it and
once you read that you will understand
there are great things that have been
happening
are happening and we are moving in the
right direction
one quick question yes um
commissioner if this amendment passes
and becomes law
do you see this affecting the safety
um in new hampshire
absolutely absolutely and and i'll just
i'll keep it as
as simple as this it is getting it is
getting very hard to recruit
and retain the best and we have not
lowered our standards
i think we have to continue uh to
support
our first responders to support them
address
mistakes that have been made be
transparent
but without that support quite honestly
you you're not going to see the interest
um and and that's that's uh uh
discussed nationally i mean that that's
happening all over the country
thank you commissioner any other
questions for commissioner flynn
see none thank you for testifying today
thank you
joseph obecky
mr chair can you hear me sir we hear you
fine
okay great my apologies i uh i believe i
pre-registered but
uh for some reason i wasn't included on
your list and with your permission
i'd like to have about five minutes i
timed myself last night so
i'll keep it to that so okay if you
i'm going to hold you to it for sure
okay sir
so uh again for the uh for the record mr
chair members of the committee my name
is joe ho becky i'm the chief of police
in hollis new hampshire
this past february completed my 20th
year service
to the state of new hampshire and i'm
sincere when i say that serving the
citizens
of this great state has been the honor
of my lifetime
i submit my testimony today in strong
opposition
to the amendment to senate bill 96 in
a bill which i originally worked on as
part of the leak legislative work group
which as introduced by representative
burch will eliminate qualified immunity
and official immunity in the state of
new hampshire although it is clear that
the focus of this bill
is directed at law enforcement the
abolition of qualified and official
immunity
will extend to many other dedicated men
and women serving within the public
service professions in the state
on friday of last week as i have for
many years
i had the honor of spending the morning
at the new hampshire law enforcement
memorial
located just outside the building in
which many of you sit
as i listen to the solemn remembrances
of the 50 names etched into the granite
columns
i thought about the incredible
sacrifices that these individuals
and their families have made to the
state
they represent the finest that the law
enforcement and corrections
professions have to offer as they made
the ultimate
ultimate sacrifice to preserve the
safety that each of us enjoys
in reflecting on these sacrifices i
could not help
but consider the events that have
occurred over the past year
where we have seen this ongoing dialogue
and conversation
about the proper role of police and
society
there is no doubt that the profession i
love is not without fault
i want to make that very clear but i'm
quite certain
that we can all agree this is true of
every profession on this planet
wesson dunn who's a retired fbi agent i
think eloquently said
and described policing by saying this
our society expects a lot from officers
we expect them to confront potentially
dangerous individuals
so many others do not have to do so we
expect them to deal with horrific scenes
that would give most people nightmares
we expect them to react with unwavering
compassion
and understanding when dealing with
people experience
the worst moments of their life
regardless
of the officer's own life stresses we
expect them to react calmly and
professionally
when confronted with verbal and
sometimes physical abuse
we literally expect them to run towards
the sound of gunfire
while others are running away police
officers live
up to these expectations every day and
this is most
certainly affirmed as you look at the
names of the courageous
individuals etched into the wall of the
law enforcement memorial
today you have heard from individuals
who are passionate
and either their support for or their
opposition to the amendment
those who support the amendment will
argue that qualified and official
immunity essentially says
that police officers and other public
servants are above the law
although i pose this amendment what is
most important for you to understand
is the impact of the removal of
qualified and official
immunity there is no doubt that policing
and law enforcement
in the united states must continue to
improve
to better reflect the expectations of
our changing society
in considering police reform we must
balance the impact
and potentially negative consequences of
such effort
it is not true to say that qualified and
official immunity prevents
accountability
for police misconduct and to the
contrary
it protects both society and law
enforcement in a carefully balanced
manner
that has been refined by the courts over
many years it permits officers to
perform their duties without
fear of constantly defending themselves
against tenuous claims
and it allows the public to recover
damages when a reasonable
officer would know that their conduct
violates a person's constitutional
or legal rights make no mistakes law
enforcement is a difficult profession
with many challenges and risks as well
as significant
intangible rewards law officers often
make
split second life or death decision
where any hesitation can result in
serious injury or death
we rightfully expect a lot of law
enforcement officers
a lot of law enforcement officers
because we entrust them
with significant power and in authority
however we should not expect them to be
injured or killed while doing their job
nor should we expect them to put their
livelihoods
in the financial welfare of their
families on the line every time they are
forced
to make a split-second life-or-death
decision
in closing i remind you that the laws
are the fabric of a civil
society we entrust law enforcement
officers
with the power to uphold and enforce
those laws
law enforcement officers keep the fabric
of our society from being torn apart
by those who have no respect for others
if you pass this amendment
eliminating qualified and official
immunity you will do nothing more than
make an already difficult and
challenging profession
even more dangerous and complicated
there is no
and this is my closing statement there
is no better reminder
reminder of these dangers than those
granite slabs
prominently erected outside the
legislative office building
for these reasons i ask each of you to
vote no
to vote no on this amendment thank you
for your time
be happy to answer any questions you
have
chief are there any questions for the
chief
[Music]
stay none thank you for your testimony
and the last person to testify is jim
kennedy
good morning honorable chairman members
of the judiciary committee my name is
jim kennedy
i'm the city attorney for the city of
concord
and former assistant attorney general
here in the state of new hampshire um i
echo the
comments offered earlier by cordell
johnston
our former chief justice of our new
hampshire supreme court now
representative
judge lynn
thomas mullins and
our senior assistant attorney general
matt broadhead
let me just say uh without repeating
everything that they've said
which i agree with in opposition to this
bill
that house bill 111 represents a
significant threat to new hampshire
citizens
and municipal taxpayers the benefactors
of this proposed legislations
are those people claiming a right to sue
for good
faith conduct by our state and municipal
employees
their benefit should not be at the
expense of new hampshire citizens
and i urge you to oppose this amendment
if you have any questions i'd be happy
to answer them thank you for your
testimony to any questions for attorney
kennedy
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and that closes the hearing on amendment
2021-12448
and i think what we will do is take a
recess
uh what i'd like to do i i think uh
rather than
take a lunch i think we probably can
take a recess come back and finish up uh
quickly with our our executive session
if
that's okay with everybody and so
uh it being about quarter past
right now why don't we reconvene at 11
30.
so we will be in recess until 11 30.
and we'll have a if i could just have
the republicans
stay for a moment and join us
perhaps in the room adjoining here we'll
have a brief caucus
i'm just going to go ahead and mute the
room for judiciary
thank you how how
jen how do you get to the caucus in the
other room
i'm representing kelly you may want to
call in to one of the members
um could you tell me real fast how to do
that um
do you have um just a cell phone number
for someone
representative alexander representative
gordon mclean
oh okay um
[Music]
i'm trying to think who just their cell
phone numbers
that that's what i would recommend since
they're kind of on the fly we don't
facilitate um caucuses party caucuses
darn i'd like to hear what's being said
but yeah i don't i
i don't have a whole lot of people's
numbers
um mike's calling me okay perfect
hey
split the difference just sometimes
so
music yeah
might i inquire before we get started
whether there are any other amendments
uh that the committee might be
considering
on sb96 or is it just this one
uh no i believe that their uh
well the committee was presented with
four potential
amendments there was the amendment that
you proposed the one that we just heard
there was an amendment that was proposed
by
representative lorenzo and there were
two
amendments that were proposed by
representative alexander or not proposed
but
were distributed
right that's what i thought so
i assume one way or the other those will
be disposed of
i'm presuming
in any event i'll call the house
judiciary committee back to order
we're here at this point in time for
executive session
this is an executive session on senate
bill 96
this is a bill relative to implicit bias
training for judges
establishing a body ward an in-car
camera fund
and making an appropriation therefore
amending juba
juvenile delinquency proceedings and
transfers to superior court
and establishing committees to study the
role and scope of authority to school
resource officers
and the collection of race and ethnicity
data on state
identification cards and
we are here for executive session we
heard i had the hearing
on the bill itself last week and we had
a hearing today on a non-journey
amendment this morning and
i think since we had the hearing this
morning i guess representative burch i'd
call upon you first today if you want to
offer that event
thank you um i do want to offer the
amendment and make a few comments
this morning are you moving the adoption
of the amendment i'm going to do that
right now uh
mr chair and committee i move adoption
of amendment 2021-1244-h
i would like to just speak very briefly
and is there a second to that
no second
yes seconded by representative kenny
go ahead representative birch thank you
um
you all know how i feel built so far
we've had a lot of debate i want to just
clarify
one or two things that were brought up
this morning one is the difference
between good faith and reasonability
anybody can claim good faith which is
why the courts
tend not to utilize that in
uh bills there were laws such as this
i can say uh i put my foot on somebody's
neck until they were dead but
i thought i was doing the right thing
let me off the hook i was acting in good
faith
that doesn't fly the
obligation to act in a reasonable manner
is the standard that the u.s supreme
court has handed down that's reflected
in the bill
so i think it's important to separate
uh good faith which is not a workable
concept
with reasonability which is uh
secondly we we heard a lot
about two or three major topic areas
one had to do with cost and i think to
put it baldly
no pun intended but to put it boldly um
we're talking about the costs
to recompense individuals who have been
harmed by government action
and there's something fundamentally
flawed
by saying oh we shouldn't have to pay
those costs
we shouldn't have to incur costs if
people were harmed by the government
that's their tough luck
i don't think we should operate that way
i don't think we have
and i don't think we should so
costs are directly related to bad acting
and that's the next point i wanted to
quickly make
we're talking here only about bad actors
and their liability period
it's not more complicated than that
we're told two conflicting arguments
we're told on one hand there will be
huge consequences
if we eliminate qualified immunity in
new hampshire
you know people are going to get sued
left and right nobody is going to
join departments um towns
taxes are going to go up every horrible
imaginable
then we're also told there's no problem
in new hampshire
both of those cannot exist in the same
universe
because if there are really no problems
in new hampshire
then costs are not going to go up
if there are all of a sudden in a
particular police department
a lot of suits maybe somebody needs to
pay attention to why there
are in that particular police department
but you can't say that there's no
problem
and if we allow victims to sue
then um this guy is going to fall in
and the last comment i wanted to make is
the issue of transparency we heard a
whole lot of patting ourselves
in new hampshire over the show over on
our shoulders
about how transparent we are and how
transparent we're working
um no or not
and that's why we have legislation a
number of areas
because we don't have transparency
number one
we keep bad police officers on the force
in new hampshire and don't take my word
for it
we have a lorry list now
we can't see yet and maybe in our
lifetime we will
but uh we don't know all the names on
the lorry list but we know for a
fact that we keep bad cops
on the job
secondly when bad cops
who are on the job act badly
we want to give them immunity
and that's what this bill is about
and the third leg of this tripod is
if there is a settlement
then in new hampshire we we bar
the harmed citizen from
talking about it and and the bad
conduct through non-disclosure
non-disparagement agreements
so by the time you put all three of
those together
i don't think we should be going around
patting ourselves on the back
about how transparent we are in new
hampshire because
we're not so this bill is an attempt
to simply say it's not as complicated
as most of these witnesses would put it
this simply says that the victims
of government misconduct
it was violation who had suffered a
violation of the constitutional rights
shall have a right to go to court
and get redress exactly what our
constitution
has said since the 1700s
thank you the other discussion on the
amendment proposed yes representative
alexander
thank you mr chairman uh i have much
respect for manchester
he presents this amendment as a change
or some changes from hb111
but the house table that earlier this
year and to be clear
i really don't think there is much
change amendment 1244 stems from a
national narrative that doesn't fit with
new hampshire
and that is highlighted by the out of
the amount of out-of-state supported
deaths
most witnesses testify and support our
out-of-state special interest groups
who failed to supply one single new
hampshire example of existing rsa is not
being accurate enough and yikes
we have almost 1200 people that signed
in opposition to this minute
in fact one witness in favor of this
amendment was forced to resign
after a series of social media posts
that were initially denied
and i would remind the committee that
that denial of wrongdoing
is a reason placed on our lord list in
new hampshire
the sponsor of this amendment argues
that addition of the use of force
language at the end of the amendment
would help address some of the concerns
raised during the session last month
i would argue it doesn't do enough there
are already causes of actions for when
officials act
in quote wanton or reckless mayor the
new hampshire municipal association has
outlined this in their letter to this
committee dated on march 1st
in which they describe the existing
avenue in place which addresses
personal and individual liability of
government employees
employees would only be shielded from
lawsuit liability if they believed their
conduct was lawful
and within the scope of the officers or
employees official duties
wanting a reckless misconduct would not
qualify
so the description by one witness has a
shooting of an unarmed citizen in a
driveway
by a police officer in my mind in most
minds would qualify as
quote one or reckless misconduct
i tabled hb 111 earlier this session in
order to give the sponsor time to fix
some major concerns
the majority of the new hampshire house
had before delivering another copy of
this bill
there has been additional language
changes offered by constitutional law
experts
and other state reps hoping to fix the
concerns by many in the house last month
amendment 1244 does not address the
major concerns of hp111
and this issue should never have been
introduced again this year the new
hampshire house has already spoken
sb-96 is an attempt to bring all groups
together
um to come up with sense solutions to
enhance law enforcement accountability
there are many things i like in sb96
however if 1244 is added to sb96 i
cannot support the bill
i want to warn the committee that adding
amendment 1244 to sb96 would simply
disrupt months of conversation and
compromise
made by the lia committee so in that way
i urge my colleagues to
support the bipartisan nature of sp 96
and please vote no on 1244 thank you
another discussion on the amendment
representative smith
thank you mr chair mr chair i
was and remain a very proud
co-sponsor of house bill
1 11. i believe
that the issue that was addressed in
house bill 111
is relevant and important
and should not
be ignored i was not
shocked this morning but was
in fact disappointed by the ad hominem
arguments that were presented
including arguments that had absolutely
nothing
at all to do with the proposal of
amendment 12 44.
the sky is not falling and would
not fall um uh
the scare tactics were i thought
um irresponsible on the part of
public employees and those who were
representing certain
interest groups there is nothing
that we can do about frivolous law
school
suits those of us on judiciary know that
frivolous lawsuits are going to be filed
no matter what
the fact that they're frivolous means
that they
are not they do not continue
through the judicial process and this
legislation or this amendment does not
increase
that um the lack of respect
that was shown this morning by
uh those who testified against this
amendment
uh comments that would indicate that
responsible public employees would no
longer be responsible
but would turn their backs or sit you
know on their hands
i found that insulting to all
all public employees
i sent to this committee um a week or so
ago
something that came from my town from
the town of durham
uh in which you all got to read about
what a careful well-run responsible
police department
that has achieved clear recognition
does and i insist that the town of
durham would have nothing to worry about
because it's careful about
who it hires it provides supervision it
provides training it provides
accountability
but nonetheless my town
manager who is uh
quite a responsible individual swallowed
whole hog
the um the information that he was given
by the municipal association and i guess
that's understandable the town spends a
lot of money
um to the municipal association so
they're not going to walk away
all of this would cause me
under all circumstances to support
house bill 111 as i did and still do
and to support amendment
12 44.
however i
find myself troubled
by the fact that
yes this is the right pew
but i believe it's the wrong church
i think that the language in the
amendment
is something that i support and i and i
will work
hard to pursue
but i think that the work that has gone
on in lee act has to be
respected a very strong argument could
be made
that there is so much support for leaked
that if this amendment were added it
would not in any way
compromise uh or or question
or put into jeopardy the passage of the
underlying bill
however all of us have seen
in this session any number of bills
where irrational illogical
ad hominem arguments ended up
compromising the success of bills that
should have passed
therefore i cannot tell you how great my
reluctance is
i cannot tell you how great my sadness
is
but legislating responsible is a
complicated issue
and in no way do i question this
my support and i hope no one questions
my support of the elimination of
qualified immunity but i
am very reluctantly going to vote
against the amendment and i will be
voting
for the underlying bill with
the hope that we will add back to that
underlying bill a section that for some
unexplainable reason the senate removed
because i want to be absolutely
consistent
in supporting the work of leak and that
would include
putting back in the one section that the
senate removed
thank you for indulging me with this
over long statement
mr chair any
other comments yes representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman and uh i agree
with my
former chairwoman uh right up until her
conclusions
she made numerous fantastic points
i think there's a lot of fear
surrounding this issue
and i don't let fear control my life
i use it as a way to inform myself
but when it comes down to the end i have
to weigh
the rational arguments i believe that
law enforcement in the state
is doing a fine job and that
there will not be a swarm of
lawsuits against law enforcement further
it's not just about law enforcement
let's let's not forget that this is
about all
employees
and then while i was not on the leac
commission i appreciate all the great
work that they did
i think this is actually instead of a
poison pill
an enhancement for who we act in that
it's a statement that says yes we trust
our police officers we know we're not
going to get sued
and it's an enhancement to we act
and in all of the
good things that they're trying to do so
i think actually sb 96
without this amendment would be lesser
and it would be more difficult to vote
for because it's not complete
without this so i'm supporting this
amendment
and if this amendment passes then i will
be
supporting sb96
as amended thank you
representative simpson
thank you mr chair you all know that i
supported hb 111
and reforms to qualified immunity and
any incentive to hire and train
employees in a professional manner
and to hold them to a high standard but
with all respect to my colleagues
sponsoring this amendment
i'm disinclined to support it today
sb96 as it came from our partner
legislative body consists of the reforms
that the liat commission came to
agreement on
i don't want to jeopardize the package
of legislation containing these
necessary reforms
by adding an amendment regarding
qualified immunity
when there's clearly not a consensus
from the stakeholders
perhaps in the future stakeholders will
come together and come to some agreement
about reforms to qualified immunity
but at this point it's vital that we
pass the reform suggested by the leak
commission
already in sb 96 so i'll not be voting
for the amendment today
thank you for your
offer and is there anybody else who
wishes to speak
to the amendment
saying then we have a motion on the
floor that's a motion
to adopt amendment 20 21 12
representative mclean now
representative sylvia yes
department yes representative alexander
no
representative melvin no
representative no
representative green no
representative kelly no
no representative
now for steven smith
yes represent
no representative
yes
representative kenny yes
representative langley yes
yes representative
no
representative simpson no
mr chairman no i had the voters
being set seven for working against the
amendment is defeated
i guess representative lorenzo did you
want to bring forward
your amendment uh thank you mr sheya
um i'd like to speak to amendment 15
10. thank you mr clear and honorable
members of this committee
amendment 15 10 makes yes
you're making that emotion that we adopt
that representative lorenzo
yes i would second it seconded by
representative smith and go ahead
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
cameron and honorable members of this
committee
amendment 1510 makes three changes to
eight to sb-96
one this amendment reinstates the
demographic data collection
provision of sb 96 that was removed by
the senate
and it strikes the study committee
provision of the spill
this amendment adds traditional and
commercial drivers licenses to the data
collection provisions of sb-96
and finally this amendment changes the
deadlines for law enforcement agencies
to submit the data to the police
standards and training council
from january 31st to march 31st
this change allows more time for law
enforcement
to process the data
now the ethnic and racial category data
collection provision of
sb-96 was unanimously supported by
members of the liat commission
i will quote the findings of the league
commission in their written report to
governor sununu
the commission makes the following
recommendations for reforms and
improvements with respect to the current
state of relationships between law
enforcement in
the communities they serve one data
collection
all law enforcement agencies should
gather analyze and make available to the
public
at least annually data on demographics
including at a minimum
gender and race for arrest citations and
motor vehicle and other
in subject stops regardless of
disposition
two new hampshire department of motor
vehicles should include a person's race
on
new hampshire driver's licenses and
non-drivers
identification cards with the
option for the person to opt out from
answering the question
all law enforcement agencies will comply
with rsa 106-b colon 14-c
by submitting crime reports to the
department of safety
division of state police based on the
specifications
prescribed by the federal bureau of
investigation
end quote now this amendment strikes the
study committee provision of sb 96
uh the senate had replace the
demographic data collection with the
study committee
there is no need for a study committee
it would be merely a pla
platitudious gesture to convene a study
committee on this subject
because the members of the league
committee spent our hours
thoroughly working on this now
transparency in government is the
cornerstone of democracy
new hampshire residents are entitled to
full transparency about policy matters
that
affect our citizens
please vote ought to pass on amendment
and in closing i would like to say yoga
yogi berra said if you don't know where
you are going you will end up somewhere
else that is how i feel about the need
for data collection
thank you
thank you anyone else wish to comment on
the proposed amendment yes
representative oregon
um yes just wanted to say um i mean
during the uh
earlier debate we had a number of law
enforcement um
officials paint a rosy picture of the uh
relationship between our law enforcement
community and those
those they serve and it certainly is
better than other places but we have um
we have the same problems um we have
the same problems that uh every every
other part of the country does so i
think uh this
uh data collection is uh is necessary
in order to uh you know as i said we
don't know
we don't know what the problem is if we
don't uh don't know what the problem is
um so probably yogi berra said it better
so i support
uh thank you mr chair mr chairman uh i
am
generally opposed and in this case the
collection of
race and ethnicity and other types of
data such as that i think that's uh
totally against the way the american
system
works we are supposed to be colorblind
and
i don't think we need to gather data to
find out that we're in some percentage
of new hampshire
uh in addition to that the idea of
putting the
information on driver's license is just
even worse
i don't know i could declare myself
anything i wanted yes i put it on my
driver's license if you could find
[Music]
yes representative marshall
yes thank you chair um i just had to
speak
when i heard that america is supposed to
be colorblind yes
when we live up to our best principles
but i think right now we are
trying to establish whether or not there
is a problem and because this is a
voluntary program
the uh it will give us hard information
a study committee is a delaying tactic
and will mean nothing without getting
hard data
to support the uh
you know whether or not we are truly
colorblind i would love to believe that
we are
but i think that we owe something to our
citizens to really establish the facts
of the matter
thank you
the anyone else wish to cut yes
representative lorenzo
i could just respond to the
representative wilbur's comments
on um collecting the race uh
data you know that part of the program
is
entirely voluntary when folks go to
renew their driver's license
they would have the option of including
the race and ethnicity
data on the license so it's not an
enforced um
you know ruled by the state
so you know it's totally optional thank
you
representative alexander thank you mr
chair um and thank you representative
dealer and so far introducing this
amendment
um i just think it's important to point
out that the league commission although
great commission
um did a lot of good work there were no
legislators on that commission
so i think that having a study committee
might be a good idea so that we have
clear separation of powers
so we do have people that are studying
this in another branch of government
so um i would unfortunately have to vote
to oppose the amendment
not oppose the idea
change my mind not going to ask the
question
anyone else wish to comment
representative simpson just real quickly
i want to
say that um the lea commission did not
have
legislators but it had very many highly
respected
um experts in the in fields of a broad
diverse array of stakeholders
who are very informed on these issues
and the best way to get to reform and
they work towards consensus
within their group um which represents
the citizens and the um residents of
granite state so i just want to say that
i um
i trust them on this and i would like to
support this amendment so that we can
get the
language back in there that will move us
closer
to where we want to be as the state
any other comments
mr chair yes representative
i'd like to respond to representative
alexander's
suggestion of a study committee you know
a study committee is going to be
nothing less than a delaying tactic
um the recommendations by the
leak committee were done in real time
and we need to respond in real time
so that we can get this program off the
ground so
i would be very disappointed
to see a study committee formed
on the race and ethnicity
data collection part of the bill thank
you
anyone else
seeing no one we're going to be voting
on
amendment 2021 1510h
[Music]
mr clerk do you want to call the role
on the adoption of amendment 15108
representative mclain no representative
sylvia
work folks no representative alexander
no
representative melvin now representative
representative smith yes
representative burke yes
representative oregon yes
representative yes
representative rogers yes
representative kenny yes
representative mainly yes
representative marshall
representative marshall sorry yes
definitively
representative page yes representative
simpson
yes mr chairman no
[Music]
the amendment's been defeated
open to further amendment representative
alexander do you have an amendment
uh so i forwarded amendment 1391 to
committee last week
um essentially amendment 1391 would
simply remove section 9 of sb96
section 9 addresses the training
covering implicit bias and racial
profiling
the language in section 9 states that
quote the chief justice of the supreme
court
in consultation with the chief justice
superior court and administrative judge
of the circuit board shall encourage all
judges to take
training every year um upon doing
research according to the code
the us code of conduct for judges a
judge should respect and comply with the
law it should act at all times in a
manner that promotes public confidence
in the integrity of impartiality of the
judiciary
a judge should not allow family social
political
financial or other relationships to
influence judicial conduct or judgment
so in order to be a judge basically you
have to be advised
this language was amended in the senate
upon looking back
from the mandatory two-hour training
every year to the language encouraging
training
so i just get concerned anytime the
legislative branch gets involved
in some of the affairs of the judicial
system uh this language basically holds
no teeth so
i'm introducing an amendment um just so
it doesn't clutter up the rsa to get rid
of this
apartment thank you
practice in the judiciary committee to
revise the separation of powers
statute means
proud about and especially as this is
in its current form it's just a
suggestion it's basically a
section of code and our books are
already
rather voluminous i only wish that
the court would respect some of the
legislation that we
have before not trying to tell us what
to do but
at least in our case we should
representative simpson
thank you mr chair i was unable to hear
representative sylvia
um it was it was muffled on the zoom i
don't know if that was the case for
everyone i'm sorry
moving the microphone thank you i hate
to make you repeat yourself
thank you just uh briefly i support this
amendment
i think that this committee has a pretty
pretty strong tradition of uh
recognizing the separation of powers
and further
this statute as it's written in
currently is only a recommendation
to the court and therefore it's
nothing more than a house resolution i
suppose in terms of whatever
probably a joint resolution and
um it just doesn't belong in our
statutes
so i'll uh i'll leave it there and that
those are the highlights
did you hear that okay okay
any other comments
there are no other comments and
this is on amendment 2021-1391-8
and mr clark could you call the roll
on the adoption of amendment 1391
representative mclain
yes representative yes
court quotes yes representative
alexander yes
representative melvin yes
yes yes representative
yes representative yes
representative yes representative smith
no representative no
no representative rogers
no representative kenny
no representative now
representative marshall health
representative no representative
no mr yes
are there any further amendments
representative alexander would you like
to make a motion um
sure mr chair thank you i'd like to move
um on to pass as amendment as offended
on sb96
and that's with amendment number 1391
second move by representative alexander
and seconded by representative mclean
that this committee recommend not to
pass
with the amendment amendment 1391
discussion
representative thank you mr chairman um
so i think um the oliac
report was uh a good good place to start
i think uh this bill now is missing
something that's uh
would be an important piece to it so i
will post it
any other comments questions
see none of this is on the motion about
to pass amendment
amended on senate bill 96.
on the adoption uh
representative yes representative
yes yes
yes representative smith
yes
yes representative
yes rogers
yes representative kenny
yes
yes representative marshall
yes representative today yes
president simpson
you've adopted the recommendation about
the past is amended
does anybody have an objection
going on the consent calendar
seeing no objection we'll put it on the
consent panel
and is there any other business that
needs to come before the committee today
that completes our uh hearings and
with regard to the report president
alexander
okay okay
any other business to come before the
committee
thank you very much we uh and we don't
have any further
committee business at this point in time
so we'll be
i guess we needed to call the chairs
take care everybody thank you thank you
mr chairman
thank you take care thank you